die ermittlungen laufen natürlich noch
aber was weiß man mittlerweile schon zu
dieser wilden schießerei hier in berlin
ja hallo ich stehe als hier auf dem
parkplatz auf dem innenhof hier in
schöneberg wurde die schüsse abgegeben
wurden
wir sehen hier auf dem boden die ganzen
markierung von den hülsen mindestens
zehn schüsse wurden abgegeben einer traf
auch hier das garagentor ein
einschussloch zeit dass projektiert wo
es einschlug und es ist eine machete und
auch ein baseballschläger zum einsatz
gekommen welche spur wird denn jetzt von
der polizei verfolgt die polizei konnte
also den das opfer versorgen das ist in
ein unfallkrankenhaus gekommen man
konnte im zuge der der absuche einen
verdächtigen mann festnehmen der iss
befindet sich zurzeit noch in der
vernehmung bei der polizei
aber ob er tatsächlich was damit zu tun
hat das ist noch fraglich interessant
ist das opfer dass wir sind hier in
einem typischen klang gebiet das nennt
sich in berlin das goldene dreieck gegen
der ganzen drogenkriminalität hier in
den bezirk das ist aber allerdings der
großfamilie geschuldet das opfer das
hier jetzt verletzt war polizeibekannt
ist auch ein ukrainer wie es heißt dass
es ohne f 24 jahre alt er ist erst im
dezember 2009 10 wegen geldfälschung
festgenommen werden im februar stand er
dann vor dem amtsgericht und dann ist
eine gesamtfreiheitsstrafe gebildet
worden von zwei jahren für oma und kam
im april erst aus der haft heraus und
jetzt ist er hier in einem
streitgespräch gewesen
ein ermittler sagte mir dass dieser oma
es sehr viele kontakte in mehreren
großen klaren familien hat und er ist ja
glück übergreifend tätig mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich je das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren